the slow horses  not typical MI5  what's going on ex-service agent  founderton  heart failure it was in a 60s smoke  drinks hey look at me yeah I'm in my  Prime  he left a note on his phone cicada  Russia's sleeper agents embedded in  British Society  give boys and girls they've been  reactivated more people are gonna die if  you uncovered the trail that quickly  it couldn't have been that well hidden  thanks  [Music]  ma'am I do not need the slow horses  digging around the past  feels too suspicious what does that  actually mean there's more to it  her has been an alert because I try to  ride the top me as I've finished  business  so there is a plane packed with  explosives  thousands of people they're gonna die  sometimes the only way to work out why a  trap has been set  is to walk into it  [Music]